four years of evidence and 150 million
pounds of public money so far so what
have we learned from the ongoing
grenfell tower inquiry well announced in
the immediate aftermath of the fire that
killed 72 people it was formally set up
in august 2017.
phase one which covered the events of
the night reported in october 2019
phase two looking at causes has been
held up by cover delays and is now not
expected to report until at least next
year
but we've already learned a lot already
and the failings are widespread
first the cladding through staff
testimonies and emails several firms
involved in building and fitting the
panels that wrapped around grenfell
tower knew the fire risk
take one email submitted to the inquiry
by a cladding manager talking about the
type of material used in the panels
known as acm
as we all know the acm will be gone
rather quickly in a fire
combustible materials had also been
packed around the windows
next inconsistencies in fire safety
tests the insulation had non-combustible
material added for testing
and then a more flammable version used
on the tower block
shoddy workmanship and cost cutting also
contributed to poor fire safety
management with fire barriers installed
incorrectly
the government also missed learnings
from previous tragedies eight years
before grenfell tower six people died in
a fire at lakenhau house in south london
another block wrapped in cladding
finally the emergency response
individual firefighters have been
commended for their bravery but on a
systemic level there was a collapse in
communication a lack of equipment and
specific training
most controversial of all was the stay
put advice issued to residents although
the government has recently confirmed it
is keeping the policy
well the head of london fire brigade
caused huge upset and later quit when
she told the inquiry she wouldn't change
the brigade's response on the night
the inquiry can sometimes feel like a
game of passing the buck but the met
police have confirmed that no criminal
charges including charges such as
corporate manslaughter will be brought
until after the final phase of the
inquiry concludes
and although government figures show
94 percent of high-rise buildings
identified have the same cladding as
grenfell tower have completed work or
started work to remove it
unsafe homes do remain and these are
concentrated in greater manchester and
london
and whilst many questions remain over
the risk of medium rise
and substantial smaller residential
buildings
so no criminal charges and thousands of
people across the country
still living in houses with unsafe
cladding